faire un point sur où on enlève de l'anc
est ce les procédures trois mois après
le drame
leur détermination ne faiblit pas pour
cette troisième et y est les membres du
collectif de soutien à jérôme la ronde
souhaité une association avec un
objectif prioritaire avoir accès à la
procédure en cours qui doit déterminer
s'il ya eu une bavure de la part des
gendarmes
quelles ont été les conditions du décès
brutal de jérôme la rose ça il faut
qu'on y voie clair et on n'a pas
d'information du tout on sait que ça a
été très violent qui a eu mort d'homme
avec une intervention de la gendarmerie
mais c'est quelque chose qui est très
fort on ne tue pas comme ça les gens en
france sans qu'il y ait de très bonnes
raisons
peut-être y at-il eu de très bonnes
raisons mais on ne sait pas le 20 mai
dernier
c'est sur ce chemin que jérôme la
rosette et abattu par les gendarmes
alors qu'il tentait de leur foncer
dessus avec son véhicule
il était recherché depuis neuf jours à
la suite d'un contrôle sanitaire où il
avait déjà essayé d'en découdre avec les
forces de l'ordre
l'agriculteur de 37 ans était en
difficulté dans son exploitation il
tenait à satisfaire les normes
sanitaires et subissait depuis trois ans
des contrôles à répétition
pour la confédération paysanne les
méthodes de l'administration doivent
songer pour éviter que ce drame ne se
reproduise
les contrôles sont énormément pénible à
vivre des cultures qui sont déjà
affaiblies et c'est la situation de
jérôme quelqu'un d'assez bly est
quelqu'un sur qui il ya eu probablement
acharnement l' affaire interpelle bien
au delà de la bourgogne
le collectif a déjà reçu une centaine de
demandes d'adhésion venus de différentes
régions et l'instruction elle est
toujours en cours sur le 30 août
prochain les membres de la famille de
jérôme la rose rencontre euros les
magistrats à salo pour connaître les
avancées de l'enquêté